show we got lots to talk about did you
know that princess diana was almost on
her way to accepting islam was she or is
this just conspiracy
theory prince harry says his mother was
chased to death while in a relationship
with someone who wasn't white
well we're not conspiracy theorists
but we have a guest of ours coming up
who's uncovered some interesting facts
we also have the russian president
defending prophet muhammad is this
reality if there is an insult against
prophet muhammed
do you think this is about exercising
your freedom of creativity i don't think
so ernest guest has something to say
about this and lewis hamilton who's he
there and restrictions from from people
from being themselves and i don't
believe in that and
religions can change religions can
change
rules can change rulers can change those
things they have the power to i guess
he's someone who's calling people trying
to call people away from islam and
towards the abc or what's that the
alphabet movement
that and also finally novak djokovic
attacked and shot at a mosque in the
town of yanya
police in birchko district also had
their hands full while across the border
in serbia's pre-boy and novi pazar there
were threats of ethnic violence
trying to prevent another genocide we're
gonna be talking about all this with our
next guest
zeeshan ali let's hear what he has to
say from smile to jenna
[Music]
my bro alhamdulillah
nice to connect with you masha'allah bro
the legend himself
show bro i was speaking to somebody and
i was like you know i'm going to be
going on a deen show and he was like
i haven't heard of that i was like whoa
whoa whoa whoa whoa
how is that even possible
when youtube was just uh
when we had a small muslim community
there used to be a channel called i
think khalifa clothing and
they used to host your show from back
back in the days
only the ogs know this show
i'm on the show
i've made it
alhamdulillah
my brother uh so what do you think uh
the topics are you up for it have you
heard that okay let's jump into it so
let's just the tip of the iceberg my bro
that is just the tip of the iceberg
so i started off with this uh you know
many people it was you know
something that was talked about princess
diana she had the uh the car accident
and
you uncovered some things can you talk
to us about those things that you
uncovered that she was possibly
potentially looking into except in islam
is that true
yeah so a couple of days ago i would say
it's approximately been a week now
on the daily mail which
i mean it's been nicknamed the daily
fail but uh it normally gives stories
that are you know biased towards muslims
and islam but they printed the story um
and like i said it's only been a week
and in the story they uncovered that
diana
on one of the flights went to one of the
oldest royal photographers
apparently he's muslim as well and he
was married to a
christian lady so diana
because she was in love with a muslim
called hasn't
so she wanted to know if it was possible
um and and what the kind of dynamic
would be for a muslim to marry a
christian and to also find out about
this religion as well because even the
royal family
uh then they're no stranger to muslims
and islam queen victoria um she
you know she had
one of her kind of people
that were close to her it was somebody
called
abdul kareem and she was very fond of
abdul kareem to such a degree that there
is a book written called victorian abdul
and hollywood's even made a movie about
that as well
so
that was queen victoria
the queen the current queen elizabeth
the second
apparently they say that she's somehow
the lineage is linked to the prophet
sallallahu alaihi
so all of these are in mainstream media
you google it and it will come on
mainstream media it's not you know
conspiratorial boris's i think great
grandfather uh apparently he had
memorized the quran as well and
boris being the bumbling buffoon that he
is because of the comments that he made
against nikabi is calling them
letterboxes and with black people
calling them you know
saying that they have watermelon smiles
i mean all this is documented so to kind
of take himself out of the hole
he kind of latched onto that and said
yeah my my great grandfather is either
grandfather or great-grandfather yeah he
was a
half-ish of the koran
so but i mean boris that doesn't give
you a get out of jail free card you
still have to be responsible with your
words
so yeah with diana she was very fond of
this man called hasn't han and because
of that she wanted to look into islam
and
because of her later relationship with
somebody called dodi al-fahid
um some say walla alam maybe she did
even take the shahada um some even said
that she she did end up
taking the shahadah
yeah because the fact that um she was
with hasanat khan and then afterwards
with dodi al-fahed and both of these are
you know they have
i mean hasn't hans from pakistan dodi
al-fahid they've got egyptian links
and they are affiliated with islam and
plus
it was very difficult for her like the
paparazzi really did not make her life
easy in fact that was one of the reason
the reasons hasn't khan said look i i
can't do this because
the paparazzi some of them were
absolutely absolutely obsessed with her
wherever they would see her they say
if you had diana on your newspaper on
the front cover your saves would go up
25
and there's one clip in that documentary
last 100 days of diana she as soon as
she got in the car she put a head down
and one of the photographers goes
put your effing head back up because you
are putting my kids through college and
paying for my mortgage
so this is a news reporter saying that
yeah yeah yeah because a lot of
like back in the days like these guys
would be savage like even now to some
degree i would say it hasn't changed uh
much but in those days they would be
absolute savages and diana i mean some
say like that's the reason that prince
harry has left the royal home
with meghan markle because he didn't
want a repeat of what happened to his
mother to happen now to his wife as well
so
yeah the royal family is no
stranger to islam in fact the british
empire ruled india or india pakistan
bangladesh it was all known as hindustan
it ruled it for approximately 200 years
and some of the crimes and some of the
things that would happen there it's
ridiculous i mean one good book is by
shashi turu i think he calls it
inglorious empire which is quite
interesting i mean
yeah a lot of a lot of stuff happened
there and the brits are well aware of
this religion
did she actually also meet his mother
and she was inquiring exactly yeah in
fact
six months before she would be writing
to the grandmother and under the
pretense of visiting pakistan and
visiting her friends imran khan who's
now the
president of of pakistan and his wife
jamai mahan now obviously they're
separated but yeah she went there and
actually there's pictures where you can
see that she's she visited their home
and hasn't in a later later interview
because he was very tight-lipped he kept
her private matters private didn't sell
the stories like even diana's mother did
she sell she sold one of her stories to
hello magazine and they had a turbulent
kind of
past as well and hasn't said yeah the
family was was surprised that i mean
what would bring a princess here because
even if you look at hasanat khan he's
not your typical kind of dreamy princess
you know he's large build and you know
had a moustache
and didn't really look after himself
really well i mean one of our butler
says that he even you know lived in a uh
i mean he called it a dirty a dirty flat
and diana would go there and iron his
clothes and this spit really good to me
yeah it really got to me when when he
then pauses and he goes she didn't even
iron her own clothes
so
these are all from that documentary last
hundred days of diana which was made by
abc
um abc news i mean they've got their own
kind of brand they have this documentary
has some of these interesting
discoveries and facts in this
documentary that people can go check up
yes exactly so it's not like i'm not
just picking out my pocket or stuff like
that it's this is mainstream information
um
is is known but a lot of people a lot of
viewers you guys will assume that
why isn't he talking about dodi alfa
with dhodi al-fayed she was only with
him for about 30 days a lot of people
don't know that but with hasn't
that what that relationship was for for
two years wait who's the the one you
just mentioned dodie yeah so dodie is
the one that she died with in in the car
and that was her latest relationship and
that's the one most of your viewers will
be familiar with hasn't han
is only known by people who are actually
following diana's life
people that only look towards the end
they'll only be familiar with dodi but
those who actually know her from before
like her butler her cook and her friends
they know about hasn't
in that documentary um yeah
so dodi was another muslim
yeah dodie was
another
muslim yeah
then but yeah um his father
at that time used to own one of the
biggest stores here in the uk called
harrods
which a lot of celebrities come to and
he had a very high rank um
here you know in
in the uk as well
and this uh the other khan he was
actually a heart surgeon correct
yeah exactly
some people say that
um well that could be the reason
speaking to a um
a psychoanalyst and he was saying it has
it's actually very interesting with what
you've said she had a traumatic past
um obviously she broke her heart and she
fell for somebody who men's hearts
so hey you have somebody with a broken
heart and she she's going to somebody
who you know men's hearts and also what
she noticed about him was the fact that
he didn't necessarily recognize her in
the hospital straight away
she
you know saw him and thought he was
handsome he didn't know her so here was
something that was also interesting that
hang on a minute everybody knows me how
can they not know me this how can this
individual not know me and even
afterwards like he wasn't fanboying her
so in that sense
you know
that really fascinated me of course
it's it's worth saying that you know
it's uh you know seeing people outside
of wedlock is haram you know we don't
condone it it's not permissible but
again
isn't it we're just talking about um
from a historical kind of context and
diana's fascination with with the people
um from muslim countries and of the
religion we're not saying for one second
that these sorts of relation
relationships are permissible and stuff
like that but what we are seeing is the
fascination
of the british empire with this religion
and with people that have
you know remnants or not even remnants
that have
because look hasn't han even if he was
not a practicing muslim even as a
cultural muslim you adopt the
um
the kind of habits and the the practices
and the rituals of the faith so even
that for her to kind of um
be drawn towards that is something that
of course
we're drawing your attention towards
yeah one last thing before we go on to
the next part is that i mean i don't
think for anybody who looks into the
shahada themselves if they look at
because naturally if someone's inclined
towards you and now she went towards his
family they want to know more about you
but then what are you connected to so
she connected him to islam
she's looking more into islam and if a
person is sincere
uh and they are looking for the truth or
even if they end up looking at islam and
they got a good heart i mean
amazing things happen like the shahada
just
acknowledging that there is one and only
one creator that i'm going to worship
this creator alone without associates or
partners you know the the beautiful pure
monotheism so when someone looks into
what is this shahada what is islam
naturally you know if you're fitra if
you're
innate this position is not totally
covered it's like open right and you're
searching for someone it's for the truth
it's gonna you're gonna connect to it
yeah 100 eddie and the thing is it's
very interesting that you mentioned
innate disposition because
there's there's a very expansive study
done by and people of muhammad hijab
will be familiar with this name justin
barrett of oxford university and he says
that faith
is innate yeah belief in one god is
innate to us we don't use this to prove
that there's a god but we say that
you know this does raise a few question
marks how is it not innate for us to
believe in the tooth fairy or you know a
the green goblin but it is to believe in
a god a necessary being
yeah the prime mover the first cause
whatever you want to call it yeah you
got big philosophers that don't have a
problem with this
yet big big philosophers that don't have
a problem with this and you're talking
about you know the shahada and the pure
monotheism and that's exactly what drew
other people like winston churchill you
can check either it's in the telegraph
or the guardian there's articles to
suggest that his family was worried that
he would become muslim wow because
look the british empire um it spent time
in india for 200 years
and the muslims were very instrumental
in hindustan and you know
granting it freedom from the the tyranny
of the british and seeing these people
fight and defend with their lives it is
bound to awaken something like what is
driving these people yeah what is
driving these people
and it's you know the more you look into
it then you look into world war ii and
you know the contribution of the muslims
and you know it's absolutely endless
yeah it's endless the muslim
contribution and even when you look at
inventions
you know one of my teachers said if you
look at anything significant that we
enjoy today there is a muslim somewhere
behind that invention you look at optics
you got ibn
yeah you look at chemistry amalgamation
crystallization you know all of these uh
you know uh processes you got jabber
yeah at the first uh university fatima
al-firi
and the list goes on the first solo
flyer abbas abney fernas and the list
goes on you know the contributions
muslims have made unfortunately and
sadly it's not mentioned
as much
however
once if a person is sincere like you
said the more you look into islam the
more you are likely to think subahan
allah yeah that means glory be to allah
like this is something ajib and that's
what happened at the time of the prophet
sallallahu where the quran was recited
and the non-muslims or the polytheists
of the time would
innately fall into prostration because
that's what it is and that's
you know what you do wonderfully as well
and you emphasize this look into islam
without the biases and the peripheries
attached to it
look into it yourself pick up the quran
yourself watch the deen show what smile
to jannah watch muslims explaining this
religion and you will see it will
resonate with you god willing and the
next part is the
once you understand this pure monotheism
and the part of the jihada is the
accepting of the last and final
messenger and you actually you talk
about you've talked about how the
russian president was also what was he
doing he was talking about prophet
muhammad was he was defending him or
what was the whole situation with that
yeah what was brilliant eddie about that
was that normally when it comes to a
non-muslim or western leaders or even
non-muslim leaders of a high rank
unfortunate unfortunately they stay very
tight-lipped when it comes to the
prophet sallallahu alaihi you've got
people like macron they will not allow
people to criticize him and people be
jailed or or you know
disrespect the flag or disrespect their
liberal values however when it comes to
uh you know respecting a let's face it
the prophet sallallahu alaihi wasallam
was you know
absolutely you know unique absolutely
unique individual and there's there's
one quote that really stands out to me
it was it's by alfons de la martin he's
a french writer and he goes
if greatness of purpose
smallness of means
and astounding results are the three
criteria of human genius
who would dare to compare
any great man in modern history to
muhammad
so this is one quote of a non-muslim so
putin all putin said was i don't think
this is freedom of speech insulting the
prophet sallallahu alaihi sallam
it peace be upon him is not freedom of
speech because it will then just cause
other people to become angry and then of
course it becomes a cyclical thing so
that was that was really nice to hear
yeah and inshallah you know he
understands and some of this sort of
stuff you know seeps into his heart and
you know because there's a lot happening
in syria as well and even with that
video is interesting you know people are
saying look but he's doing this in syria
look
of course you know we condemn what's
going on in syria that they are our
brothers and sisters but however with
we're taking this comment and this point
of his we're not saying that just
because you know we're acknowledging
this we're acknowledging everything else
that he does no that not at all we're
not saying that we're not washing
anything yet people need to be held
accountable for what they are doing
especially when they are killing
innocent people however when it comes to
the prophet sallallahu alaihi sallam he
is the only leader in modern times that
has defended the prophet on such a a
large platform and a scale and for that
alhamdulillah we are grateful yeah we
are we are grateful
and to be
and to be fair eddie i was actually
speaking to muhammad hijab we were we
were doing we were just talking and
discussing sometimes what happens ideas
people say how do you know
how do you know muhammad even existed
mike how do you know
and then we say that's actually an
interesting question
but you can say that about jesus peace
be upon him moses peace be upon him but
you this is a claim you cannot say about
the prophet muhammad sallallahu alaihi
why because we have independent
non-muslim sources that have been dated
to the 7th century
that
verify that the muhammad sallallahu
alaihi
was indeed an individual
living at that time
yeah and it coincides with certain dates
and events that took place and this you
can find this in a book called forbidden
prophecies by abu zakariyah and the
three sources both to the seventy
seventh century first one is a nestorian
chronicle
the second one is called the doctrina
jacobi nupa baptizati and the third one
is bishop sabias of the house of
bhagavatunas so the prophet sallam is
somebody that is unique
somebody that is appreciated
for his
you know
completeness as a human being and that
is why
he is the only one worthy of being
called the final messenger hand selected
by allah
an example for us
we're told in exams you can't copy
somebody and people say allah why is god
put me in the situation my i don't know
why what's happening allah said no
problem i'll give you somebody and you
can copy him copy him in an exam so this
exam allah is permitting us to copy the
prophet and we will pass this exam no
problem in sha allah and look at the
life of the prophet when you read his
seerah you know
something as small as how we even go to
the toilet how we cleanse ourselves how
we speak to our parents you know how we
groom ourselves such details such
precision and this if this is not
cognizant of the truthfulness
and the validity of the prophet
sallallahu alaihi
is to be honest
and there you go that's what she would
have accepted that there's nothing
worthy of worship except the creator god
almighty allah and muhammad who you're
just talking about peace and blessing be
upon him is the last and final messenger
sent to mankind they'll be the shahada
and automatically you accept jesus moses
abraham all the preceding messengers
that came before him with the same
message of islam submission to the
creator not the creation easy to
comprehend easy to understand easy to
accept if you're sincere and you're
looking for the truth now tell me here
we just want to touch upon this before
we
get into what i really want to talk
about what's been really on my mind but
let's just touch upon this lewis
hamilton
i don't really know much about him you
talked about him and it seemed like he
was someone who was trying to he was
trying to get people away from islam and
towards this uh i was just a abc
alphabet movement
so the
lewis hamilton is a very famous formula
one a grand prix driver uh he he's
actually a racer for mercedes yeah and
he's known for coming pole position yeah
right at the top he's fantastic amazing
but when it came to lgbt movement that's
where he messed up yeah they were in
saudi and in saudi of course there was
pressure from other people look this is
what they do this is this this is that
and then he gave the impression that
islam amongst other religions should
change
to
validate the lgbtq
movement now firstly this goes against
freedom of speech yeah this goes against
freedom of religion freedom of thinking
why should you change
your religion to
lgbtq which let's face it there is very
little evidence supporting it yeah you
just they have a very strong lobby and
because of that it's being enforced in
hollywood and the likes but all it is
is saying that look we should be able to
love whoever we want
say okay you're able to love whoever you
want then what about pedophiles are you
okay with that no no no no we're not
okay with pedophiles but you can love
whoever you want okay then can i love
animals no no no that's that's that's
not right that's not right right so you
can't love animals okay then uh
can you love your parents yeah you could
love it can you have a relationship with
your parents no no you can't what if
you're wearing protection
hmm person that follows the liberal
framework cannot categorically say
sleeping with your own brother sister
mother father if you're wearing
contraception if you're above the age of
consent is wrong they simply cannot say
that and that's why the likes of
lawrence krauss in his debate with hamza
sauces was unable to say it was wrong
richard dawkins wouldn't ask the same
question
couldn't say it was wrong even apus who
was asked he couldn't say it was wrong
either i mean is this what you're
calling us towards
we're three-year-old children you know
tavistock is one of the lgbt clinics
here in the uk they have entrants and
they're allowing kids as young as three
to switch genders
i mean what on earth is going on and
then you have the average population
that have to pay their taxpayers money
towards this now i don't understand how
is this freedom of speech if i'm paying
for this i'm being forced to pay for
this if i don't pay for this i can be
held liable i can be imprisoned and
sanctioned
i honestly don't know where freedom of
speech has gone and when you look at
lgbt
which has his roots in liberalism you
cannot prove it from first principles
it's as simple as that you look at where
it goes john stuart mill jeremy benth
bentham and this is issues with the harm
principle yeah there's issues but when
you look at islam it's objective harm
principle is subjective it's up to you
whatever you want to do if the pleasure
outweighs the pain good if the pain
outweighs the pleasure bad but in some
situations that doesn't work yeah what
if you're in a boxing ring what if
you're you know
yeah what if you're working out it
doesn't work there so that's that's what
we're saying come
to the objective law set by your creator
who knows you who knows your society
because even when it comes to human
rights and stuff like that yes we're
bashed over the heads with it and islam
has no issue with it but we're saying
with human rights should come human
responsibilities
yeah
human rights is all about what you owed
me me me me but islam says what about
mother's rights tell me one human rights
article that talks about mother's rights
it doesn't and that's all islam is
saying be just you talking about
abortion yeah my choice my choice what
about the father's choice what about the
grandfather's choice
yeah so you have to take the whole so on
the face of it it looks very good but
when you probe into it you realize
there's so many contradictions and
inconsistency
and that's why it's clear it is not from
allah not from the god who has created
us because his law is something which is
all-encompassing we have the pixel
he has the picture
beautiful mashallah
are you familiar with bosnia
yeah that's definitely a a uh a dark
kind of cloud
over our history and something that the
muslims bosnia is one of those countries
as soon as it's mentioned they just you
know evoke something within us that you
know reminds us of a period of sadness
and you know
of
of a time the ummah was incredibly weak
and it's unfortunate and sad that you
know bosnia yet again
is in the firing line
and um
[Music]
and that's why sometimes eddie you know
when people talk about yeah yeah
you know we need to be doing this and we
need to be there speaking out speaking
why is nobody speaking out against
bosnia and what's going on there
why is nobody speaking out against
what's going on in afghanistan yeah i
just saw you know what eddie today i saw
um
this was on sky news yeah and i
screenshotted this because it it's
absolutely appalling
and
i'll i'll read the headline to you this
is the headline
yeah
it says well one of the headlines is
parents sell children and kidneys to
feed starving families subhanallah
and the other one is
uk pledges to release more aid after
grave warning a million children could
die
now in all these articles when you
scroll down
this is not because of the terrifying
terrible taliban
this is because
banks bank accounts and assets have been
frozen
afghans cannot access these accounts
and because of this
they are literally
on the brink of starvation
they can't access what accounts their
accounts
yeah bank accounts they cannot access
the money it's not about them needing
aid the money that they have
they cannot access they have
why can't they access the accounts it's
been frozen why is it before it's been
frozen by the the likes of america in
fact um yeah they call it sanction
yeah afghanistan has been sanctioned yet
this this has happened to venezuela this
has happened to iraq this is called
economic warfare yet they've left
afghanistan but now they're economically
depriving them and you notice even when
you get a chance read these news
articles you see it's only towards the
last quarter they'll tell you about
these sanctions the first three courses
about the terrifying terrible taliban
and what they're doing but the reality
of it comes towards the end release the
assets release the money let them use
their own money
and what it and you know what eddie
they're calling it collective punishment
that's what the political commentators
are saying that you're punishing
the people because of you your problem
with the taliban
yeah and that's the thing you know when
it comes to the ukraine eddie
they're very quick yeah yeah britain we
we're pledging yeah yeah france we're
pledging yeah yeah why because russia's
involved
but bosnia you've got all that going on
in bosnia kashmir you got all that going
in kashmir and with the uyghurs you've
got all that going on but no no no there
no no we're just going to you know sit
back what happened to human rights there
what happened to freedom of speech there
it seems that it's only used when it
seems to be convenient it's a tool
yeah and we fall for it
again
and again
and i hope bosnia is not a repeat of
what happened before
and i hope the ummah wisens up to what
is going on and i'm glad you brought it
up because unfortunately sadly we can't
just rely on the 10 o'clock news to give
us information about these we actually
have to sit as a family
and look at alternative media to give
our kids a bigger understanding i mean
they're about to enter a metaverse i
mean they're not even going to be part
of the reality
so if they're going to enter this it's
your duty not to moan and just stick
them in a madrasa somewhere and hope
that the teacher will teach them
everything and anything they need to
know no the first madrasa of the
children is the home
and that's where we need to start
i want to get your reaction to this you
heard me mention um this
famous tennis player he's from the
actual area there in serbia his name is
uh
novak djokovic so we were trying to get
because you know how the story goes as
soon as someone is affiliated you know
with some extreme element some stream
group
you know he's questioned he's called to
condemn
so now these events are happening and
usually you want to get ahead of it
create awareness before things boil over
so i'm going to get your reactions to
this and
let me know what you think shooter
covered his weapon with the names of far
right role models as he drove to a
mosque in christchurch he played a
traditional serbian military song and he
cited convicted serb war criminal
radhavan karajic in his manifesto
and he's not the only one
serbian nationalists have inspired other
white supremacists including anders
breivik who killed 77 people in norway
in 2011.
the rise of the far right
like so many other european countries
serbia is riding a wave of
neo-nationalism
the difference here is that the
movement's role models are convicted war
criminals
men with violent pasts whose acts of
aggression are not just excused but
publicly glorified
[Music]
alleged supporters attacked and shot at
a mosque in the town of yanya
police in birchko district also had
their hands full while across the border
in serbia's pre-boy and novi pazar there
were threats of ethnic violence
your thoughts
you heard them what they were chanting
uh shoot the moss
what do you think people eventual
influence like novatch
novak djokovic you know what do you
think responsibilities like him you know
people because there's not too many of
people like like him out there
and others you know getting ahead of
things before things erupt what are your
thoughts when you see this and what i'm
talking about i think that's a very good
point that you're making in fact it
reminds me of a few instances that have
taken place
um wylie who was a uk grime artist who
said
some anti-semitic remarks
and because of that he pretty much got
cancelled from all of his social media
so social media took the initiative
there was a walk out on twitter until he
got removed from the platforms
um then nobody was allowing him to
perform
and then a couple of days ago
um there was a picture of jesse lingard
and marcus rashford
um i'm not sure if it was marcus
rashford but i do know definitely was
jesse lingard but yeah i think yeah it
was marcus rashford as well
and they were asked you know how comes
you're even seen with wiley and because
of that because of how anti-semitism is
taken seriously
um they immediately condemned it yeah
without any hesitation these guys are
england players marcus rashford he plays
for manchester united as well
you know one of the biggest clubs in the
english premier league and then like we
were mentioning before lewis hamilton he
was asked to condemn what saudi was
doing and he was very quick to do so
because it's his responsibility then
when jk rowling made a few comments
about the lgbtq movement she's the
author of the harry potter books pretty
much most of the cast
from the likes of
daniel radcliffe who plays harry potter
and the actor who plays weasley and
hermione granger all of them they they
condemned j.k rowling's comments so the
question here eddie is why the disparity
why the disparity what makes this
situation different
first thing that we'll say is
muslims is it because
they are muslims
and just a
few weeks ago i guess emma watson
decided to post a
something on her instagram in solidarity
of palestine now
she just posted something which shows a
much and said solidarity is a verb or
word yeah she said something like that i
think it was verb
and then a lot of people appreciated but
appreciated that but unfortunately as
sadly some of the diplomats like israeli
diplomats they use that as an occasion
to beat her over the head with the
anti-semitism label which a lot of
people were saying hang on a minute how
on earth is the anti-semitism
so you can't even defend the palestinian
people without being called an
anti-semite
so
it seems that any time somebody even
messet ozil when he stood up for the
uyghurs
china dropped in from pro evolution
soccer even when they were playing the
games they wouldn't mention his name
they had a vendetta against them yes so
it seems whenever we're talking about
such issues
pertaining to muslims
either when people stand or speak up
they are curtailed and they are just
pushed down and made to be quiet
or
nobody just speaks up
now how are muslims meant to feel when
this happens and occurs yeah how many
more times can you feed us with the
pacifier no no it's all in your head
it's all in your head because i'm sorry
but when you see a certain trend
even on a mathematical graph and it's
going upwards you're naturally going to
assume that you know it's going up
exponentially
yeah that's that's what you do it's
called following the pattern
so i'm sorry but this just reveals the
insidious islamophobia that is present
among certain people
and
to be honest if this does reach mr
djokovic
and you know hopefully
you know assume the best maybe he's
planning a statement as we speak but it
is very important for people that are
from these countries to take a stand
yeah to take a stand
and uh speak out against oppression
regardless of the shape or form that
it's taking and even in my many videos
i've been talking about what's going on
in india and initially it was happening
to muslims and i said if you do not stop
it
hate does not discriminate it will spill
over it's like a glass you need to stop
it don't just say yeah we don't like the
muslims you've got to stop it because
it's oppression not because it's
happening these people that you don't
like
that you don't get to pick and now
unfortunately and sadly the hindutva
terrorists and extremists rather
it's spilling over to christianity
christians aren't being allowed to
practice their religion freely
i hate to be the bearer of bad news and
say i told you so yeah and we do not
want the same to be happening over here
and it is the responsibility like you
said of people with big platforms to
speak out because when when emma watson
spoke out it sent ripples across the
globe
ripples it got people talking now yes we
should be following celebrities
but we cannot deny that they do have an
influence and that famous spider-man
line with great power
comes great responsibility
would you have a problem condemning you
know if muslims were out there chanting
shoot at churches
you know or making threats towards
non-muslims would you have a problem
condemning this
the thing is eddie
we had since 9 11
muslims like you said it's become part
of our dna to condemn any little thing
that happens even though we're not
supposed to
it's not our responsibility i get up in
the morning have my cereal get on the
bus go to work some nut case has done
something on the other side of the
planet and somehow i'm responsible
somehow i need to apologize for that
crazy yeah yeah it's ridiculous like
muslims have been put on the back burner
we've been put in the back seat and this
you know this is having you know it's
giving us this victim mentality
but you know if you want to condemn you
condemn and the thing is look if
somebody asks me without a shadow of a
doubt
muslims condem any harm happening to an
innocent person that goes without saying
that goes against the koval scripture in
fact if the islam that the the
dictionary definition of islam is peace
and where this cult of evil hang on a
minute right there
all these gangs and cults they have like
really cool wacky scary names
why on earth would a cult or scary bunch
of dudes call themselves peace
it just seems counterproductive it
doesn't make any sense yeah and you pick
up the quran
and that's exactly you'll see
peace
you see
good logical reasons analogies stories
yeah and this is your lord speaking to
you and this is why it's very important
for us to think objectively and not get
sucked into this media storm and frenzy
because fair cells
hate cells
today is the muslims
tomorrow will be somebody else before us
it was the blacks before it's been the
jew jewish community it's been the
communists it's been the bavarian
illuminati you know that used to
actually be a group there's been loads
it's the catholics
you know they've been there's been loads
of skate scapegoats in the past and now
it's just the turn of the muslims
unfortunately and sadly but
for a muslim to be shouting that sort of
stuff on the street it will be on the
front papers
front papers okay in the uk we have
something here called the prevent
program they'll be picked up they'll be
picked up
and some some you know there's such
thing as
um uh you know secret courts here in the
uk
and you know certain things in which you
can there's one thing that's actually
gone to the house of lords where if you
have a dual citizenship which means even
if you're born in this country but your
parents are from another country if the
government beams you can be removed from
this country many muslims have had their
citizenship
revoked you have schedule i think seven
schedule seven that you can be stopped
on the airport sorry in the airport for
many hours hours on end
so muslims are bearing the brunt of this
and you know what's sad eddie
you know what the reality is
the
let me tell you the reality here
since 9 11
since 9 11 73 of the extremist incidents
have been done by the far right
now nothing to do with islam now we're
talking about the
far right who are actually if we want to
if we want to mention a religion you
know what religion would the far-right
be connected to and this is not to pick
on any religion yeah it's not but i mean
it's a factual statement to be honest
eddie and the religion that they are
mostly adhering to is christianity
yeah it's christianity and in fact there
was um
there was a brilliant study that was
actually done
um
it's
and and in there it took
um all the kind of uh
killings in the name of religion that
has actually taken place
it's taken place
and you know what they concluded which
religion has killed the most people
during that time
it was christianity
it was christianity um
would i be able to share this on the
screen yes go ahead and this is i mean
as i often repeat i mean this is not
again not picking on any religion but
it's kind of ironic that any time
someone gets connected like you're
saying anyone gets connected somehow
to islam he was eating maybe some arabic
food right or he was he said assalamu
alaikum or and he's not even really
practicing but anything to connect him
to islam is going to be front page news
all right
so you have you have these war criminals
guilty
of the following counts
count two genocide
count three
persecution
a crime against humanity
count four
guilty on 10 out of 11 counts a litany
of cruelty
murder a crime against humanity here he
was today inscrutable but guilty of
atrocities committed in a war that cost
over 100 000 lives created millions of
refugees and became the darkest chapter
of post-war european history
what they call you know chutneys i don't
know if you heard of this term chutney
have you heard of chutneys i haven't
ever heard it see everybody's heard isis
boko hara these are these have been
plastered all over you know the media so
this element this is who these andrew
brevlick and the christ church
terrorists all these people were
connected to them if you look into this
so this is that group that's in this
part of the the world and you don't see
anybody you don't really hear them
talking about them you don't hear you
know much you don't you haven't heard
much but if you look into it you'll see
that this is
this is uh what's
uh brewing in in this part of the world
[Music]
europe's biggest killer since adolf
hitler
1995 in eastern bosnia serbs are
fighting muslims
[Music]
don't worry malice tells this boy we'll
look after you a lie within hours the
srebrenica massacre began around 8 000
muslims murdered
at the same time laddich led the four
year siege of sarajevo
the longest siege in modern history ten
thousand died from serb shells and
snipers the international court of
justice indicted marriage for genocide
and crimes against humanity and if the
the leaders if the people out there who
have influence from the church to the
politicians don't come up if they're
just silent when you hear people ranting
shoot at the mosque
this is not like one or two these are
you know imagine you coming out and
you're seeing these mobs of people on
the streets and you just came over the
worst genocide looks since world war ii
you know they had rape camps 50 000
women they say around in these rape
camps muted men women and children the
river became a mass grave
but 24 years on the memory of horror is
being deliberately erased
and nowhere is it more obvious than here
ramza muhich was raped here at the
villain of las hotel
other survivors say it was used as a
rape camp
ramza says she was attacked by milan
lukic a commander in the white eagles
militia later jailed for mass murder
bosnian muslim men and boys were
selected for murder not only on account
of their muslim faith but also because
of their gender
the women suffered a different fate
srebrenica was the culmination of a
brutal campaign of ethnic cleansing
across bosnia herzegovina in which 20 to
50 000 women and girls were victims of
genocidal rape
and you know and we talk about never
forget and this is something that
obviously we're just trying to create
awareness so before it boils over and
right in the heart of europe again
another massacre you know another
genocide and nobody's you know the novak
jova kitchens the the church leaders
everybody's quiet you know ask people in
this area is there any news reports is
there anything that people are speaking
out against you don't hear much so
inshallah we can do some good
and get people to speak up you know and
work together to stop these things you
know on both sides if it's on any side
you know if it's roots i'm doing it hey
we'll be the ones to come up invite us
we'll come and talk against it 100 same
thing on the other side where is people
speaking up you got to speak up there's
an evil speak up against it what were
you going to show us
yes and just the the 73
statistic that i gave
those of you that want to check that up
it's uh that was actually in a report
prepared for congress by the government
accountability office and this is it
right here
no no no that's the 73 that i mentioned
and then you've got adl and of course
europol that have mentioned that since 9
11 73 of the extremist attacks have been
done by the far right now here what you
see on the screen eddie is a very
interesting study yeah it's been done by
dr naveed sheikh i think he's of
cambridge or one of these prestigious
universities
and this is a comparative
quantitative study of the mass killings
in history
yeah so in history um you can see
that
the
religion that has the tallest bar
i've underlined it in red
is christianity
yeah it's christianity with
178
million
and then
you see there islam in green little tiny
one there 31 million and if you check on
the right
i've underlined christianity which is
ranked to number one
and then islam is actually ranked number
six
it's ranked number six
but unfortunately and sadly
according to a georgia state university
study
they discovered that muslim terrorists
get four and a half times more coverage
than non-muslims
so there is clearly an inherent bias
here and that's the reason why muslims
are seen to be cons constantly
condemning
because
the system unfortunately and sadly does
not favor us and that's why it's very
important that brothers like yourselves
and like myself and the viewers watching
we do whatever we can
from our side to be involved in the
struggle in whatever means we can even
if you're a whatsapp warrior even if
you're a father who's
teaching their two kids about the
reality and and what's going on and
giving them you know the complete news
rather than just the
filtered news that we get from the
mainstream it's very important that we
do use this as a wake-up call and
educate those around us because
sometimes people say i don't have these
big platforms and this and that look
well
allah knows best maybe me and eddie
yes we may have the numbers and we're
reaching loads of people but maybe we we
might not reach that one person that one
malcolm x that one muhammad ali that
needs to be reached and maybe you guys
that are watching with your you know you
know whatever means you have and you
have that sincerity and you're able to
you know
find that new malcolm x that we need
that new muhammad ali that we need
yeah so people like this will never
underestimate yourselves and never never
underestimate how you are in the sight
of allah as well a couple more questions
before we come to uh to an end so you
mentioned four and a half times i've
actually read studies that it's actually
you know you're going nice but i've i've
read that it's actually even much more
than that press coverage and i want
people to wrap their minds around that
like you know when something's
highlighted and it's often you know
repeated over and over and then it's a
big difference before it gets on the
front if it's on the front page and then
it's on for you now you did something
it's not back you know people don't even
go to the back of the newspaper it's
somewhere over there right so that even
the numbers where the amount of press
coverage that hits the
the main front
part of the newspaper uh gets those main
headline attractions all that stuff
consider all that
and it's it's very sad you know what i
mean so we have to be consistent and um
yeah one other thing i was thinking
about and i wanted your comments on this
because a lot of this a lot of these
things stoked from and it reminded me of
a hadith from prophet muhammad peace and
blessings be upon him who said this
nationalism it stinks you know what i
mean so in this part of the world where
you have people who are let's say
serbian croatian doesn't matter if
you're italian polish i mean islam
doesn't discriminate you know it's
something nationalism okay you have your
national identity no problem but when
people try to make their nationalism as
it's better than the next man's or
whatnot and separate people based on
this this is something that islam
actually calls against because you have
so many serbians croatians polish
italians who actually look into islam
and they accept islam for its beauty you
know for all of the teachings you know
what i mean so what it what is your
comments when you hear about people when
you these stokes of and people
politicians using this to divide people
like they've done in bosnia based on
this nationalistic pride
yeah i would say that's a a very
good insight that you've given and this
is a technique that the british have not
hidden in books by mark it's called
secret affairs he openly mentions this
in his opening chapter where he talks
about the british talking
about the importance of divide and
conquer even when they're using it in
when they were using hindustan which is
again a collective term of india
pakistan and bangladesh and he said yes
this
hindu versus muslim thing will play in
our favor in fact they did this in
afghanistan and you know in iraq as well
the sunni shia divides and in
afghanistan northern alliance and
taliban and you know the likes hazaris
and you know
the groups actually play in the favors
of the elite
yeah it's easier for them to rule when
people are fighting amongst each other
they call it breads and circuses yet
this was used by the emperor yeah he
made the colosseum for this reason that
the people are too busy being
entertained by the breads and the
circuses
whilst we
are doing what needs to be done this is
sometimes what i say to these wannabe
gangsters as well that they are fighting
over territory when let's face it these
territories are owned by the politicians
if you really want to get these
territories then find out actually
what's going on and don't fall into
these stereotypes and these traps that
you're supposed to fall into
yeah if you're coming from a
a background where you're grown up in
the hood or in the estate as we have in
the uk you are destined to fail why
because you have cheap gmo ingredients
with sugars and the likes and your
education system
you know it's it's part of culture to
not you know care about education too
much what you're doing is you're falling
in that trap
yeah so what you need to do is realize
that you are in a trap
and then try to get out of that trap
yeah that's why when you listen to these
interviews of snoop dogg and these guys
when they say oh you know you don't get
that much respect in the hood he's like
i don't care
i needed to get out the hood and now i'm
out the hood these people are just
hating
and that's what it is
and that's what it is and we need to
realize this and really mobilize they
say you know at the time of the battle
of badr the muslims were 313 against an
army of a thousand armed to their teeth
but the muslims too until they had
sticks and spades but because they were
people of action people of substance
they were able to do something
substantial
today the muslims are 1.8 billion but we
cannot do
what the badri sahabas could do
and one scholar gave a brilliant example
he said in those days the mosques were
unbaked
but the people who emitted and who came
out of the mosques were baked
today the mosques are baked
but the people who come out the mosques
are not baked
so may allah make us people of action
people of substance
that we you know definitely invest like
these discussions are
here to evoke you guys into researching
them yeah we're just giving you the tip
of the iceberg of what's going on we
only have an hour and we're conscious of
time and conscious of you know the
people and retaining you know you guys
and your attention but
really this
inshallah should really
inspire you to research and really
introspect
and do something
and uh
i think that the most important thing is
for our viewers if they're new to the
channel new to hearing us
and they want to know more what
princess diana was almost
and was there even talk about her
accepting islam taking the shahada what
do you think they should look into what
she was about to accept why she was
about to accept it what's so beautiful
about the shahada that was so beautiful
about islam
would you advise people to look into
that definitely eddie in fact i would
say if you look at any field you'll find
a muslim there who has been fascinated
and enthralled with islam enthralled you
look at one of the most famous comedians
on the planet dave chappelle he talks
openly and candidly about how islam
inspired him
you've got
footballers like paul pogba he's being
interviewed he plays for manchester
united and he's talking about how islam
has you know really helped him and
assisted him and subhanallah when we
look at
actors when we look at you know sports
personalities i mean
you're no uh stranger to habib
i mean habib
has spoken masha'allah openly and
candidly about the influence he is the
best he is the best of the he's the
cream of the cream when it comes to mma
and he is somebody who subhanallah
is so
affected by this beautiful and amazing
religion and you have even the likes of
like we discussed putin were leaders
saying that you know what we need to
give respect we need to give respect to
the likes of the prophet muhammad
sallallahu alaihi
yeah so again it's the same thing the
message that you give which is why
why
and that why
will be satiated once you pick up the
quran and you
read what your lord
wants to tell you
beautiful and you mentioned the quran if
you're out there you want to get a free
copy of the quran you can go to the
deenshow.com pick up your free copy
today and this was with our brother
zishan ali from smile
to jannah and if you want to check him
out go to smile to jannah thank you
brother for being with us here on the
dean show and going over some of these
uh my pleasure any time bro anytime may
allah bless you preserve you
i mean i mean
allah